la mienne excusez moi je comprends mal
plus fort numéro faire le tour de ses
réticences face à face au billet vert
profite pas ces cigarettes à mon mari
est-il fatigué comprend 56 famille
apparemment pas les six enfants du
mackenzie dernier il m'a fait la cus
tout à lui jean pierre est impossible de
le renommer life tapage nocturne que la
fenopaci villa au sec avec mon mari on a
failli appeler liffe us qu'elle me
faisait du tapage malaisie dit bonjour
et bienvenue sur mon mari les flics il a
pas osé derogy ses copains jeudi auprès
son enfant nous est ce qu'elle est et
non dites moi tour et monsieur vous dire
et il regarde le ciné club juste et des
mines les mine eut passé et tous en vo
par encore pas mal madame brut vola en
bo en version autochtones
elle est pas mal de fil à me dire que
c'est tout elle comprend après celui en
français en plus de regarder films un
autochtone alors c'est bon pour donner
un genre à la vente
vous avez vu résultats comme moi il est
11 heures du matin sur les son feu vert
si c'est pas malheureux de voir ce
record
surtout pour une femme vous savez ça
c'est des gens qu'on pas d'horaires pas
ce que je vais vous dire moi le dimanche
parfois ils déjeunent avait mis des
demies passées par sa une
sur un bon centre que nous choisirons
d'avoir bien comme converse à suspense
et de reportages en effet les sites
empreints de souvenirs de tout cela elle
doit être malade pour madame j'ai dit
que la province d'erbil pensée dont
j'étais en courses à ces bobos d'octobre
le nasdaq affiché comme ça mois
d'octobre à paris
ils n'ont annoncé ce matin si vous
deviez coûté au final ils y ont même
annoncé la télé hier soir je suis sûr et
un envoyé
on va mettre nos têtes sont tombées
c'est pas grave la conscience a voulu
ramasser
même mon corps est elle même le piqué
n'est plus tôt mais oui vous savez c'est
comme ça qu'elle a monté tout trop ce
que ça c'est que ces mariages mais
derniers jours avec tout ce qu'ils
comprennent qu'on me donne pas besoin de
chercher plus bas depuis qu'elles sont
juniors c'est est ce qu'on est tous les
gosses me baby cédera côté des 1100
t'ouvrir les à-côtés débourser pour vous
dire
sinon du poitou la lessive ordinaire
quelle horreur mlm et adoucissantes dans
maya vraiment du centre de l'argent
dépensé beaucoup bossé sancerre ses
draps housse est membre au corps et à la
faillite en belgique et elle était dans
l'escalier en train de distribuer le
courrier
je sûr qu'elle est en train de la d562
5e 6 a même fait un dernier set qui
prend la pilule est franchie les
mam'zelles tu as bien fait et voilà
pierre géantes rouges et les plaquettes
bitar email mobile de l'immeuble
j'ai tellement attendu à 10h00 aller
chercher favolosa widmore me ferai pas
bien mais là le look plutôt que laisser
des plaques est vide elle ferait bien
ménages et de 4 à vous demander comment
et c'est parce qu'il m'a dit mon corps
et tall sall 6000 c'est pas vrai et la
vielle avant nous dire à nous
malheureusement comme concierge qui
parle lorsqu'il m'arrive incidents
seront commandés rien vous savez moi je
trouve ça incroyable
cet enfant est un mari chômeur au
chômage
mais ça je me dis ça c'est
caractéristique des chômeurs si vous
respectez ma musique
il avait payé quand ils ont pas les
mains occupées par faut bien qu'ils
s'occupent au dessus des hématomes au
visage et vous dire ma foi oui
personnellement moi j'aurais pas
supporté marie son voeu bas avec votre
maria pas de risques a mis son métier ça
une position bien stable à ses
représentants à bretelles et stoppe sa
tante aura des pantalons sur la bretelle
à vous l'avez dit ma foi ça me fera des
pantalons 40 à droite m
comment ça se fait qu'il ne vieillit pas
eu d'enfants gbagbo marie jo sont les
roues dans la pâte à haut je suis bête
vice et ses marques et d'un sens ça
c'est pas plus mal parce que c'est vrai
regardez les mamelouks l'iphone et des
cinq six enfants passer à mes parts
finalement ils n'ont pas le temps de
s'en occuper
je peux vous dire quelque chose même le
look elle les accompagne pas des kouassi
moom mais il sait pas pourquoi mais plus
vous vous réveillez vous mais du rêve
aux canadiens pour qu'ils accompagnent
cet enfant nicole tille non confondues
nous regarder elle s'était du coup ni
froid
et encore des banques à la récréation
ils l'ont relâché ce mot pour mam
lellouche quand même un drôle de vie
cette petite femme là c'est vrai le
mariage civil est dix fois plus grand
khan afridi fois moins car elle très
facilement annuellement vous m'avez s'il
ya nous faisait la parole j'ai pas
retrouvé les paquets numéro plein visage
en disant ménages trouvent des parties
cinéma selon les amis du poids on va
voir où les malades ça le cinéma à notre
échec pour divers d'aller au cinéma
franchement elle aussi n'est menacé les
choses en restaient là au cinéma et vous
dites moi monsieur trop faumont
m'arriver l'erreur du cinéma l'eni
vashem le cinéma je veux dire d'abord
qu'on y va on paye des 25 26 provinces
et les soit plus la dernière fois que
j'étais j'ai raté le dernier métro
nyamilima jamais pardonné sa valeur est
gérée de main truffaut mais moi j'ai
vous dire une chose lâche prête à
regarder cinéma télévision date on est
bien content et je me fais un petit
plateau repas puis du poulet je mange de
la cuisse à ma convenance je suis pas
profit mais dis moi je veux dire mon
mari y va tout seul parce que 10 c'est
un homme et une femme c'est pas donné
mais nous on appelle ça comment l'accès
à ces mois cadeau d'anniversaire
vert-olive pas ses mots à lui maintenant
supporter des chrysanthèmes de monsieur
veut dire à ma belle mère est pas très
bien portants si jamais vous servir
on ne fera pas qui va tu me dis là
concurrents préparent à manger pour les
petits la cour de l'école mais qui les
ont comblés mégarde à la cantine des
écoles marcel argile attendu par tous
les hivers austral garde qu'a fait le
juge thomas truffaut lui les pauvres les
précaires forward enfants qu'avant des
sous doués comme et l'on peut même pas
manger tout seul leader même s'il est
mal edith et marcel il en voudrait
jamais robe assez sûr c'est sûr en plus
si vous saviez le tapage qui font de
week-end ces bruits et le céleri ma
pauvre dame et vous avez qu'on va être
tranquille dimanche qui vous pique nique
e salon du bricolage
bah alors mon mec tranquille alors vivre
lundi matin s'avéraient de mètres il
faut aller à valence